the defender of the veil tom car kenny
here remember me we don't think we're
boyfriends by mistake you know you let
him think it and you love it
either the dead will defeat the living
in which case all our troubles come to
an end or life blowing out
not then
you've made a name for yourself
playing charming sociopaths why are you
so good at it i don't know
maybe i'm a charming sociopath thank you
sansa i have known you since you were a
girl i've protected you having played
those roles you know you do start to
take on a little bit of that um into
your own personality
i suppose if it's getting you somewhere
you start doing it yeah but i don't go
around like killing people or anything
like that
is that part of the appeal i mean is it
invigorating to make aiden gillan
disappear i don't know because i used
them to be aiden gillen you know my name
isn't even gillan
that's my mother's name and it was that
was a name i took on um when i
became an actress so it doesn't feel
like that because i feel like aidan
aidan gillan is is the actor
person and the other one oh right yeah
him
that's a whole other thing
uh yeah making it disappear yeah so the
whole thing's in it it's bigger yeah it
is yeah no being an actor yeah the more
it's it's such a it's a really weird job
you know and it is it you were act
you're kind of acting all the time i
bring good news
my friends in the north tell me sansa
has escaped winterfell what was the best
thing about being littlefinger to be
invited in to be part of that
universe if you like which is
intricately and
crazily
magically created thing to be trusted
and to be allowed to bring something of
yourself to it and make it your own and
then it becomes this big pop culture
phenomenon gather the knights of the
veil
the time has come to join the fray
i suppose if you're doing something like
the wire and all that it's a gritty
drama you're not really thinking of it
being a construct i understand you're in
no position to criticize the mayor nor
would i
nor would you
whereas and that is almost like you're
part of one of those you know very
intricate pop-up books or you know the
world's best snow globe so to be part of
a toy set
yeah how do you feel about the world
cheering in unison the moment you got
your throat cut did they
sansa
i beg you i think characters like that
they're expected to get a comeuppance i
always tried to make people feel for
that guy regardless of what he was doing
i loved you
but i was actively trying to get them to
root for me and to think i was you know
a good a good person
[Music]
in a smaller project you've even played
the part of a semi-famous actor
struggling
with often only being recognized as that
man from the telly yeah does that happen
to you anymore it's more obvious that
people come up and they think they know
you and then you kind of think you know
them and you're not really sure what's
going on and it's the whole
weirdness of that happening on a daily
basis you look a bit like that bloke but
you're older and not as interesting and
um
not good looking
let her go
do you ever worry that littlefinger will
be your version of alec guinness's
obi-wan kenobi the role you cannot
escape oh my sweet wife
he did well out of that
um i hope i'll do something else of
course that's the most seen one but you
know i don't care i mean if that's if
that's the way it goes it's fine